wie bewerten sie denn den plan einen
rechtsanspruch auf home office
einzuführen das ist glaube ich
realitätsfremd also ich glaube dass die
arbeitnehmer und die arbeitgeber
zusammen gerne entscheiden wollen
also eben beispielsweise hat mir noch
ein kollege geschrieben alter kollege
vom früheren job mensch ich habe mich so
an das home-office gewöhnt kann mir gar
nicht mehr vorstellen zurück in die
firma zu kommen
es gibt ja leute die machen jetzt zu 100
prozent ist also ich glaube das muss
arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer zusammen
entscheiden da können wir nicht als
staat sagen wir entscheiden jetzt wie
der arbeitnehmer zu arbeiten hat also
ich glaube so ein hybrid format glaube
ich wird sich eher durchsetzen also dass
man teil home office macht und ein teil
präsenz nur wenn man mal ehrlich sind
wir reden jetzt alle sehr positiv über
das thema es gibt natürlich auch die
negative seite und in den
geschichtsbüchern in den nächsten 20 30
jahren bin ich mir sicher wird dieses
thema home aus wills als der schlüssel
schlechthin zum neuen arbeiten wieder
gegeben dass es jetzt wirklich so eine
transformation gab unrichtige
beschleunigung nur fakt ist auch dass
darunter viele branchen leiden sachen
nur mal eine ganz große
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft hat ja
eine hohe zahl an mitarbeitern im
sechsstelligen bereich die wollten in
den nächsten zwei drei jahren auf bis zu
50 prozent runter im reisebudget
übrigens nicht aus finanziellen kosten
sondern aus zeitmanagement gründen
das heißt wenn 50 prozent weniger fahren
dann kriegen die auch nicht mehr mit der
lufthansa oder mit wem auch immer die
übernachten nicht in einem
geschäftsmodell
die fahren doch nicht mal mit dem
taxifahrer von münchen zum hotel oder
von madrid die ersten auch keine pommes
mehr an der pommesbude was ich damit
sagen will ist
heute ist sicher dass wir die
kapazitäten in vielen bereichen nehmen
sie das hotel lesen im business-bereich
im geschäftsbereich nicht halten können
und das macht es ja für uns als politik
so herausfordern das ja auch das was
herr palmer und andere eben sagte und
der kollege vogel auch dass wir jetzt
zwar brücken bauen müssen für die
wirtschaft aber wir können keine
künstliche wirtschaft erhalten jetzt auf
dauer denn dann wenn klar ist dass
beispielsweise 20 30 prozent der hotels
kapazitäten nicht mehr zu tragen sind
weil einfach die gäste nicht mehr da
sind dann kommt das schlimme erwachen
und deshalb müssen wir jetzt schon alles
tun damit wir die branchen- unterstützen
bei dieser transformation